[Music]
part of us kept hoping that he would
reappear and it is painful you know I
think our first reaction was just
incredulity
migrant rights are human rights women's
rights are shooting right stop resisting
I wasn't comparing Trump to Hitler I was
comparing Hitler to try
[Music]
and just couldn't take to anyone the
last thing he wanted was to put his
problems on you
[Music]
the investigation into Jamarcus obtuse
disappearance continues turkish
authorities believe he was murdered at
the Saudi consulate in Istanbul the
journalist hasn't been seen since
entering the Saudi consulate more than
two weeks ago today The Washington Post
published Jamel Kershaw G's final
article prophetically entitled what the
Arab world's needs most is free
expression and it was this very
expression that seems to have cost the
veteran journalist his life it's a
column he filed the day before he
entered that Saudi consulate and
disappeared and we hadn't published it
until now because part of us kept hoping
that he would reappear and do the
editing with us as he normally did we
finally decided that the message in it
was too important and we wanted to share
it with our readers in English and
Arabic by the way and the message in it
is kind of encapsulates you know what he
stood for which is the need for free
expression especially and everywhere but
especially in the Middle East and the
absence of it has something that was
just is holding back his own country
Saudi Arabia and so many other countries
in the region it must be very painful
that is editing it without him reminder
of his absence as I'm sure the last two
weeks and a few days must have been
hugely painful for you at the Washington
Post how have you been coping with the
uncertainty and these allegations he's
terrible grisly allegations and details
coming out of Istanbul it is painful you
know I think our first reaction was just
incredulity I mean that's something this
monstrous and also stupid could be done
by another government was almost
unfathomable and so from the beginning
we tried to keep you know some hope
alive that he was going to reappear I
think it's difficult but it's also
I think people in this newsroom are
totally committed to the mission of
doing good journalism on this the way we
would do on anything and in this case
good journalism means finding out what
happened and then from the point of view
of the editorial side the opinion side
which I had insisting that there be full
accountability for whoever is
responsible and that there can't be
business as usual with a regime that
would do something like this if in fact
they did something like this there's
been a lot written about Jumeirah
keshavjee in the last couple of weeks a
lot of it nonsense I know that
personally having having met him and I
don't recognize the man that some people
have depicted in their accounts and
descriptions of him but what kind of man
is he or was he we don't still know what
tense women to use and what kind of
journalists well I mean you know that's
partly why this last column is so
heartbreaking but also so important
because it really captures what he was
fighting for remote most of his life and
as you say there's been a lot of
nonsense put out by Saudi trolls and
some conservative American trolls but
Jamal aside from being an extremely warm
gracious funny person who was always
trying to help other people understand
his country and his region you know
really he was a journalist he got
himself fired any number of times in
Saudi Arabia for not toeing the company
line
he went to Bahrain to start a an
operation there got himself fired on the
first day for printing a dissidents
column that the regime wasn't happy with
and he finally left his country not
happily because he felt he could not
express himself and that if he had this
opportunity to come out and try and
speak the truth and try and spark debate
and and try and encourage free
expression in the Middle East when so
many of his countrymen were muzzled or
imprisoned for doing the same that he
had a responsibility to do that even at
some risk and
so he did and that's who he was well
inside like 9/11 the documentary maker
Michael Moore took aim at President
George W Bush and the war on terror his
latest movie is Fahrenheit 11:9 named
after the American version of the date
that Hillary Clinton didn't become
president Friday would beat you just
trying
and surprise surprise this time it's
President Donald Trump in the directors
crosshairs dream yes the whole rotten
system that gave us Donald J Trump
because Trump did not fall out of the
sky Trump Trump is the result of decades
of behavior on the part of corporate
America our political system the whole
shebang
that gave us Trump you know one of the
important ingredients of getting Donald
Trump as president is first dumbing down
the country to accept somebody like that
as president of the United States that
began a long time ago with the debasing
of our education system closing
libraries making it difficult for people
to go to university student loans that
are 120 thousand dollars to get a
college degree this is this all is part
and parcel of how we ended up we're
worried and you blame a lot of people
including yourself actually yes I am I
am also partly you know the mainstream
media Barack Obama triangulating
Democrats and the electoral system but
there is reality in there which is quite
a lot of your people if I can put it
like that actually vote for Donald Trump
well when you say my people I assume you
mean people that came from working-class
you know I signed up for yeah yeah but
but actually the the facts show that
Hillary Clinton won the vote of the
people who earn under 30,000 dollars a
year so that needs to be kind of put out
there I think that the people think that
while Trump supporters are all these
white working-class guys that part is
true if you're saying that that I am
Trump's demographic I am I am a white
guy over the age of 50 I have a high
school education and I'm pissed off so
that that would normally that would make
me fit in well with the Trump voter
buddy you saying it was okay well I
understand why they voted for Trump I
understand why a lot of them voted for
Trump you have to understand eight
million
Barack Obama voters voted for Trump
okay so we're not just talking about you
know appealing to racists who are for
Trump I'm talking about there are there
are many people who just wanted to throw
a Molotov cocktail into the middle of
the political system and blow it up
because the system had not served the
working people very well over the last
few decades do you really think don't
Trump is a fascist and all see if it's
the end of the film you put his voice
over Hitler
yeah I'd yes I wasn't comparing Trump to
Hitler I was comparing no I was
comparing Hitler to Trump the big
difference you know if I was gonna say
that Trump was Hitler I put a little
mustache on him and a swastika and all
that no the the film shows Hitler
speaking at a large rally and Donald
Trump comes out of his mouth that's my
version of satire and I'm what I'm
trying to say here is that what we have
in the 21st century is not the fastest
some of the 20th century there was a
book in the 80s
written by Bertram Gross called friendly
fascism and that book said that the
fascism of the 21st century would not
come with concentration camps
responsiveness it'll come with a smiley
face and a TV show
she's one of the most famous faces in
Hollywood but off the silver screen
she's an outspoken advocate for women's
and children's rights but earlier this
year amber heard the Syrian refugees
living in these za'tari refugee camp in
Jordan I spoke to the actress about her
humanitarian work alongside Syrian
asylum seeker zina McCarthy I am from
Syria basically and I came to the
Netherlands four years ago as an asylum
seeker so today I am participating in
the one young world summit in order to
make the voice of the Syrian refugees
heard in the politics as well as in the
business in order to make sure that our
voices are also here in in those in
those fields that are important to the
whole world
and that's also why I am here it's
important to amplify those voices and
you know I had the honor to spend time
in a Syrian refugee camp earlier this
year in Jordan I've done a lot of work
on the border of the US border which is
where I'm from and you get a sense of
whether you've been there or not you you
can't ignore it it's a global issue it's
a global crisis it's a human issue
you're choosing to bring attention to
them at a time in your career when I
imagine you're having plenty of calls
emails asking you to do you know
auditions or films etc you're riding
high career-wise why have you made the
time for this why does it matter so much
to you nothing could be more important
to me
migrant rights are human rights women's
rights are human rights and wherever
there is justice denied justice and of
itself is undermined it's not an issue
that affects a group of people or a kind
of person if it affects you or you it
affects me
the sport of pride prowess bitter
rivalries and big personalities even
those who aren't fans are likely to
remember this fight I won you some flash
photography coming up
the meetings between David Haye and
Derek Sherman wasn't even their actual
fight back in 2012 looking a bit
embarrassed there guys thanks for
joining us in the studio we rolled with
our older now that was so David you have
now become Derek's
manager yes which we can't really
believe considering how much you hated
each other yeah now it's forgotten you
know we had our issues in the past and
we sort out like like men do we we
squashed whatever beef there was we've
known each other we sort of see each
other out and about on the circuit and
ever since our fights
everything's been amicable as far as
whenever I've seen him has always been
respect there whenever you share the
ring with someone the respects always
there and you know Derek gave me a shout
and said you know what could I do for
him if I was looking after him in terms
of managing promoting training you know
what you know how would I make him
better
exactly exactly so I told him what I
believed he could do you know after
watching his last fight against Carlist
a camp on skype box office he pulled off
an amazing come-from-behind victory
knocking out a fighter and you know
Joshua couldn't knock out and I saw
something in him that night I've never
seen before
and you know with the right
infrastructure with the right team
around him which I believe I bring I
think he can he can he can reach the
stars now he wants to be the heavyweight
champion of the world you know and I
want to assist him you know I want to
make sure that he gets you know he gets
well compensated for his you know
putting his life on the line as he does
time and time again and make sure that
everything runs smoothly and we see the
very best war Chisora well you know
kudos for that knockout it was fantastic
what what do you want because you must
have had to have done a lot of forgiving
and forgetting to go to David Haye and
say please help me get better please
help me get to the top it's not that it
was things happen you know we had a
fight and I lost and then after you lose
a fight as a in boxing it's more like
you know what I've lost two fighters no
I got knocked out
that's what happened to me so I was like
okay enough respect for the man and then
I saw why he was doing
would use Korea so I figure out he can
help me achieve wanted to achieve right
now we've got some very happy news now
we're getting this from Kensington
Palace the Sussex is revealed that she's
pregnant with a baby Jew necklace spring
the announcement was made just hours
after Harry and Beckham arrived in
Australia and the news has many wore
watches Down Under
very excited Princess Megan touched
Camilla's hand and will you remember it
for the rest of your life
[Music]
she's beautiful understand having the
freedom to do anything I want there's
been wonderful discipline of being in a
group
I started playing Joy Division at first
celebrating music because it was 30
years since Ian died suddenly then I
moved into new order this moment well in
committed suicide he was suffering from
epilepsy and it led to a very bad
depression the treatment product in
those days was actually quite barbaric
and I think the thing is is that the
knowledge about the disease was not very
good even people are a lot more better
able and better informed about it now
how did that impact on us well nothing
you can imagine it brought Joy Division
when they were really on the cusp of
becoming all our hard work over three
years was just coming to fruition when
in just couldn't take it anyone and you
know I mean the guilt of something like
that happening to you stays with you
forever I mean I'm not been immune from
that I have their clinical depression
and yes is you know I mean it's it's
it's odd to think how many people suffer
and suffer in silence what happened with
Ian was that we were too young
to even be able to contemplate what we
should do and there were very people
around him that were professionals that
didn't know what to do either
so the thing is is that why I've learned
is that you have to ask for help and
seek it whenever you can and not
suffering silence because unfortunately
Ian was a wonderful human being and the
last thing he wanted was to put his
problems on you so what he would do was
he would always say to you I'm okay stop
worrying everything's fine you wanted
that more than anything in the world you
switched off and of course he was alone
again and I think that that's the lesson
that I've learned is he son I always
tell people so you have to do it you
have to you know Express what's
happening to you
what triggered your clinical depression
diese my divorce
absolutely suddenly she's one of them
things that was the first time we met
wasn't it yes it was 1995 I was very
impressed I mean it's an easy traffic's
not the it's not a shock for people when
they go through something as traumatic
as that and yeah it did and I must admit
it was like falling into a glass pit
that you couldn't find any way out of
and I was treated badly in that I was
prescribed badly and I ended up having a
few friends kicked me up the booty shall
we say that pulled me back and saved me
I I have to say yeah it could have ended
very differently yes it could and I do
think that in the back of my mind you
know I've been through it once with a
great friend and colleague and I knew
roughly what was happening but it's
still not easy to deal with so yeah I'm
very happy I'm very happy Caroline had
mental health issues as well - yes
mm-hmm
so we were probably a bad combination at
that time very nicely over when she died
it was a challenge there wasn't it yes
she was a challenging person but you
know love is blind deaf dumb and stupid
no it's a challenging well she was
difficult you know it's I think the
thing is is that the job that we both
did
putting your self right in the firing
line if you like makes everything makes
you sensitive to everything else
and it also makes you vulnerable you
know you're in the limelight you know
and people act differently towards you
and sometimes it's not helpful so no it
was very sad it was very sad and she was
abusive yes she was yes how did you deal
with that by not telling anyone who I'm
suffering in silence no and again you
know I learned later many times that
it's not I mean you know as a man it's
it's one of those things as the master
they don't like me what the thing is is
that I ended up very ill through it and
when I came to do the book I realized
that I didn't want anybody else to be
scared and it's amazing how many of my
close friends have come to me and said
thanks for saying that because I've
never been out saying it happened to me
that was the worst phone call I've ever
had in my life well she was at the
ariana grande concert she was right at
the front and she was just about to get
the train home because there's always
that unfortunate thing with the arena
it's such a terrible to get away from me
and words that she was gonna leave yeah
ariana came back on and did the Encore
she decided to stay so she stayed and
she was still there when the bomb went
off now my brother's a policeman and he
was telling me that Ariana Grande's
encore saved two thousand lives well
that's what they reckoned she only
played those three minutes extra two
thousand more people would have been in
that for you leaving and so it was
incredible I thought the woman handle
handled herself superb Lee I think she
you know if it was possible to come out
of something well then she did she
really was if such an awful thing as an
artist to think that you could ever put
any of your funds in danger it's just
terrible so my daughter was trampled in
the rush to get out I thought was badly
damaged she had to go to hospital as one
of the casualties but she was home and
that was the nicest feeling I can't
begin to imagine she's suffered terribly
from it over the year and it was funny
even small things like I notice that she
always has to leave a bedroom door on
now where she never used to do that
before so you know yeah we do we've
talked about a lot yeah and she went to
the concert with me when Ariana did
think of the benefit concert and you
know we've tried to exorcise the demons
but you know there's so many children so
many people's children that I knew who
were there that night and some of them
saw much worse things then Jessica did
god bless her on November the 23rd he's
14 years on November the 23rd and I've
been sober that I thought my life was
over when in reality it was just
beginning and I've achieved more in
these 14 years and I'm a happier person
than I've ever been unstrung grrrrrr
than they've ever been so it's funny
it's you know you took that one step
think it's all over and then realize not
long afterwards the you know your life
is just beginning
vary on what direction you take you know
well I just try to be a good husband a
good father
there's nothing else I can do
[Music]